why do birds suddenly appear every time
you are just like me hey red how are you
oh I'm horrible we're gonna be working
on managing our anger through movement
eagle heron pick up warrior Mouse tree
rabbit this focus King pigeon and of
course downward duck look sometimes when
I get upset I have been known to blow up
excuse me party foul greedy I am a pig
unbelievable yeah where can Network Oh
where we're going
we practice this a hundred times give it
to me ah we're gonna come in again
this new year
when everyone around the world is busy
making resolutions we all know aren't
going to last make a promise you know
you can keep to just be yourself nice
chat with you the Angry Birds movie
wishing you a Happy New Year in theatres
this May in 3d and RealD 3d
yes
get into it
you
hey how are you oh I'm horrible mr. riah
this seems to be a recurring issue angle
am i a passionate bird oh yes but why
does it matter that we're not the same
Bobby anger might be contagious he
started it
reading I am a pig what's a pig show
them how we do it how you doing is that
what I think it is scuse me
those are fragile right not yours you
won't make it I will get feel unwelcome
and you're not asking basic questions
well this just got awkward doesn't
anyone see what's going on here
the whole world is in danger and it's up
to us to stop oh my god if anyone knows
what these pigs are up to its Mighty
Eagle Eagles like wisdom get out of
there don't spit in his nothing holy men
don't swallow it mmm
it's him
Oh
horrible turn of events horrible
won't mr. red yes he would be a
recurring issue wheel angle am i a
passionate bird